dans cette salle docteur choquenet
explique les causes de l'obésité
tout d'abord la sédentarité puis
l'alimentation nous sommes au centre de
soins la valériane à trinité l'obésité
définit comme une maladie chronique et
évolutive
une maladie qui gagne du terrain en
martinique le poids s'accumulent et le
point s'accumulent de plus en plus tôt
chez les enfants et jusqu'aux adultes
que nous sommes aujourd'hui
donc effectivement si on ne prend pas
conscience aussi en attend comme
beaucoup de personnes attendent les
premières complications
c'est sûr qu'après le chemin et reste
difficile parce que c'est une pathologie
qui se traite sur la durée mais la
difficulté elle est là parce qu'il faut
faire avec
ici on apprend à calculer son indice de
masse corporelle les infections des
systèmes digestifs la nutrition pour
faire la différence entre un repas
équilibré et des régimes inefficaces
voire dangereux
non seulement on lutte contre l'obésité
mais on lui aussi contrôler l'autre qui
nous regardent qui nous trouvent trop
gros et tout ça donc on essaye de faire
les choses donc on est obligé de faire
un régime
mais on constate aussi après avoir perdu
certain nombre de kilos on reprend le
double ou le triple
en martinique une femme sur deux est en
surpoids et l'obésité touche aujourd'hui
trois femmes sur cinq avec ou sans
complication